Hey
so this isn't matching up with this and
I'm not sure which one's right you just
I'm down the original part yes me do you
have what were you saying before about
the paperwork he doing now
go stop worry Kevin do you feel okay
you feel good body strong sleep big last
night yeah I think we should get him to
cost yeah all right Kevin come with us
no he's always been like that
no he hasn't I mean he's gotten worse
over the years he's making a statement
it's an ironic comment on our
expectations of him a funhouse image of
our model of Kevin you keep diktat me
mechanic not speak English but he know
what me mean when we said Cardinal go
and we best friends so me think why
waste time say lot word when few word do
trick Kevin I appreciate what you're
trying to do tank here we have a word
code the same way we have a dress code
and what we're talking about is
basically the speech equivalent to just
wearing underpants sometimes words you
know need use but need me poor talk talk
but save time more success does it save
time though cuz we've been here for
about an hour
know me fault Kevin at most you're
saving a microscopic amount of time any
small time make big time and what are
you gonna do with all this time SeaWorld
Kevin you can't possibly save enough
time to see the world check em now are
you saying see the world or SeaWorld
SeaWorld oceans fish jump okay China no
see right there that's the problem with
your method cuz I still don't know if
you're saying SeaWorld or see the world
and it's taken a lot of time to explain
it fine fine I'll talk normally
when me president desi
you